We've learned that
axial precession,
it's not a change in the
tilt or the obliquity
of our rotational axis, it's
a change in the direction.
And over a long period
of time, 26,000 years,
it kind of traces out a circle.
And the main affect
of that is that if we
wait long enough that our
rotational axis, or you could
say almost the
North Pole, will be
pointed in a
different direction.
And so if our rotational
axis is pointed
in a different direction
after a long enough time,
then the absolute
point in our orbit,
if we use the sun as
our frame of reference,
the point in our orbit when
we are most pointed away
from the sun, or when the
Northern Hemisphere is most
pointed away from the sun,
will be earlier in the orbit.
Now I emphasize that
that won't necessarily
mean earlier in our calendar,
because our calendar,
by definition, takes
into consideration,
I guess, or it's
more based on when
we are furthest tilted away
from the sun or furthest tilted
towards the sun.
So even though if we wait 1800
years, like the example I gave,
we will be most tilted
away from the sun.
The Northern Hemisphere
will have its winter equinox
at an earlier
point in the orbit.
According to our calendar, it
will still be December 22nd.
If our calendar
instead was based--
and it's not based on
this-- but if our calendar
was based on the
exact point in orbit,
then our year would be about
20, 25 minutes longer every year
and then the date for
the start of winter
actually would go back.
1800 years later, the date
of the start of winter
would be November 22nd.
But that's not how we
measure our calendar.
Our calendar is actually
measured from equinox
to equinox.
From December 22nd or 21st,
there's slight fluctuations
depending on the calendar,
but that will always
be the date that we are most
pointed away from the sun.
That will not be necessarily
the date at this exact position
relative to the sun itself.
And that's why the actual
perihelion does change.
Because if this is
always December 22nd,
and if we, at first, assume
that the perihelion is always
at the same fixed point in
space relative to the sun,
although that's not
exactly the case,
but if we make that
assumption, then it
will be further and further
after that December 22nd,
further and further
after that time,
that we are most pointed
away from the sun.
And that's why you have
this kind of pushing back
of the perihelion.
Now, what I want to
add to this video
is that the perihelion
itself is also changing.
So if I draw the sun
again, and right now
our orbit looks
something like this,
and I'm going to exaggerate
the eccentricity of it
so that the perihelion
and the aphelion
are a little bit clearer.
So right now this
is the perihelion.
This is the aphelion
based on the way
I drew it right over
there in different colors.
I don't want to show that's
necessarily where Earth is.
Perihelion and
aphelion, there is also
a rotation of this,
of the perihelion.
And sometimes this is called the
precession of the perihelion,
or perihelion precession,
or apsidal precession.
These are all very hard to say.
And so if we wait several
thousands of years
our orbit might look a
little bit like this.
The actual perihelion
will have rotated.
So our orbit will
look like this.
The actual ellipse would
have rotated a little bit.
You wait a little bit longer,
it might look like this.
And obviously, I'm
once again talking
about over thousands
and thousands of years.
From a year-to-year
basis, you really
wouldn't notice the difference.
But what that does
is, is we talked
about the axial precession,
that this change in direction
of our rotational axis,
it takes 26,000 years
to complete one period.
So 26,000 years from
today, our polar axis,
if we don't think about
our rotational axis,
if we aren't too concerned
about the actual change in tilt,
which there will be some
small change in tilt,
but 26,000 years
from now, our pole
will roughly point in
the same direction again.
We would have completed
one whole period
of axial precession.
However, it does not take
26,000 years for whatever
our date of perihelion is today.
So it's in January.
I actually don't
know the exact date.
You can look that up.
But whatever that
data is in January,
it will not take 26,000 years
for it to be that date again.
And it would have taken 26,000
years if the perihelion itself
were not changing, if it
always stayed fixed over here,
if we did not have this
apsidal precession.
But since it is
also changing, you
could kind of say it
is over 1,000 years
moving in that direction while
our January date is moving
in that direction, they
will actually meet sooner,
so that the precession will
be back on whatever date
it is on January, less
than 26,000 years from now.
And actually the exact time, and
I haven't done the calculation,
but this is what
I've read, is that it
will be 21,000 years from now.
And then on top of that,
if that's enough for you
that not only is the direction
of Earth's rotational axis
changing and the
tilt is changing
and that the perihelion
and the aphelion
are also rotating around,
it's also the case
that the eccentricity of the
orbit itself is changing.
So over long periods
of time, Earth's orbit
becomes more or less eccentric.
And we've learned that
almost circular has--
well if you're circular
you have no eccentricity
and then you can become
more and more eccentric,
which means you're
more and more of kind
of this flattened out ellipse.
And these cycles occur,
these eccentricities cycles
occur over approximately
100,000 years.
And so to revisit the
Milankovitch cycles-- and once
again this is a theory.
We're not sure whether this
is necessarily causing our ice
ages or whether
this is necessarily
a major influence over
long-term climate change,
but the theory of
Milankovitch cycles
is that over long
periods of time,
if the eccentricity
changes enough
and if it coincides with when
the perihelion and the seasons
also coincide, maybe that's
enough to start an ice age.
Or maybe that's enough to
take us out of an ice age.
And actually, if you want
to throw something even more
on that, the actual
plane of our orbit
also changes over time mainly
because of interactions
with the outer planets.
Anyway, I'll leave you there.
As you could imagine, this
is a very complex topic,
but hopefully you now
have an appreciation
of all the different ways our
orbit can change and maybe
start to think about how that
might affect our weather.
Although, we don't
necessarily know how it does
or whether it even
really does affect
going into or out of ice ages.